for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out move
University calm thank you and enjoy so
in this video I just want to talk about
ionic versus covenant compounds in a
quick overview in summary so first up is
method of formation how is it they ought
that ionic compounds form well they form
via the transfer of electrons right one
atom either gives gives up its electrons
entirely to another or you can think
about it as one atom steals electrons
from the other right but the point is
either there's a complete transfer of
electrons from one to another okay
whereas covalent compounds that doesn't
quite happen instead they share
electrons okay so there's a sharing of
electrons sharing is caring with coconut
compounds okay now when we think about a
unit of a covalent excuse me of an ionic
compound the ionic compounds unit is we
think about it being a formula unit
which tells us the ratio of cations to
anions in a crystalline array of a
sample of that ionic compound that we're
talking about whereas covalent compounds
they have individual units called
molecules right the distinction between
them is port is important I mentioned it
a little bit more in detail in the
previous video okay now the state of
matter at room temperature I don't
really talk about this in the intro or
in either of the two videos before
because it's really just a quick fact
that you should know at least in my
opinion there are tons of details about
it but when it comes to ionic compounds
they are typically solids at room
temperature right think about things
like examples like like sodium chloride
right table salt is a classic example at
room temperature it's solid and if
you've ever tried to melt salts you've
probably failed now with covalent
compounds they are typically liquids or
gases at room temperature okay I think
about classic example is is water right
water is a liquid at room temperature
another example would be something like
h2 gas or o2 gas we breathe in oxygen
gas that's a gas at room temperature so
if we think about
there's a matter at room temperature we
can also sort of basically determine
whether they're melting points of
boiling points would be high or low now
I just mentioned that if you've ever
tried to admit to to melt salt you
probably fail so with the ionic
compounds their melting points and
boiling points are often tremendously
high okay whereas covalent compounds
melting point boiling points are
relatively low right it's fairly easy to
boil water right if you've ever cooked
pasta you just put on the stove and soon
enough it'll it'll boil right also with
with water it'll it melts at what is it
zero degrees Celsius right 32 degrees
Fahrenheit so covalent compounds have
relatively low melting point and boiling
points some examples of each I've
already mentioned a few ionic compounds
NaCl is a classic example mgcl2 is a
classic example there of course many
many more types of ionic compounds
covalent compounds where did I put here
co2 and water carbon dioxide gas and h2o
is water well I hope the video is
helpful thanks for watching if you found
that video helpful don't forget to Like
comment subscribe and share with friends
thank you and happy studying